on this episode of the pop culture
decoded show we take a look at all of
the fantasy Easter eggs in the trailer
for Pixar's new movie onward and we
discuss what makes bong joon-ho such a
great director
[Music]
so we're going to start today with
Pixar's first official trailer for their
new film onward I'm really really
excited about this film they're their
level of details and like Easter eggs
are always great and it seems like there
are a lot of like hidden things that
people didn't notice do you want to go
through them yeah definitely so this is
one of the first shots in the trailer we
got a new look at Chris Pratt's
character barley his jean jackets
covered in these fake band names that
are fantasy themed so you can see smote
right here it says Hydra and there's one
that says Hades over here he has a d20
dice like from D&D here you can see on
his wall there's a poster for puddle of
mush which is just a fillet I'm the band
puddle of mud music seems to be Barley's
kind of passion and that extends to the
like stereotypical van that he has the
band van the band van yeah
someone is license plate over here you
can kind of make out most of it and it
says Guinevere which is reference to
King Arthur's wife and then also in the
van it's really hard to see but if you
zoom in here it's a siren on the radio
which is a reference to the sirens
mythical creature a couple more from
this convenience store that they go to
there's a lot in here some of the ones
that we liked were the misty light which
with a mountain on top so reference for
the misty mountains from Lord of the
Rings and then some others cloak and
cola orange quest for Orange Crush I
just want to add that they played with
Old English throughout the trailer and
their cup is in wheezing giant size just
medium okay that makes a lot sense
there's a recurring one in this shot
where this punk pixie creature is
holding triple dent gum which has
appeared in Toy Story and in inside out
there's also a potential reference to
weekend at Bernie's and then the last
one to talk about here they pull out
this book it says quests of
you're on the front and then when they
open it up you can see it's actually a
D&D guidebook seems that D&D is a thing
in the hair world even though it's a
fantasy world so it's fun to see where
they'll take that premise yeah that's
really fun Nate what did you want to
talk about today right so this week I
think it's the perfect time to talk
about bong joon-ho
you know parasite is having a limited
release but the reception is amazing
tickets are being sold out people are
talking about it
it is the Palme d'Or winner of this year
which is you know the winner of Cannes
Film Festival and he is one of my
favorite filmmakers and I think one of
the best filmmakers to work in like our
modern time and the clip that I brought
today is from the movie mother which is
a Korean film
this scene in particular I think is one
of his greatest just because it is such
a good scene that just embodies what the
film is about yes it's this is actually
very early on in the film and it's very
very simple it's basically about the
mother she's sort of like chopping up
hay that sort of her work and while
she's doing it she looks out the window
and watch is sort of like her son
goofing with with another guy who's sort
of a bad influence and like they're
standing in the middle of the road
all these things are just like passing
by and we see the lay just getting
closer and closer to her hand and the
suspense from that is incredible and he
does that by you know like some of the
most basic editing techniques which is
he really speeds it up as the blade is
cutting closer and closer towards the
hand until he like almost gets hit by a
car and then we just get a series of
shots here and just it's such a dynamic
scene that just shows what he's capable
of and also shows you know like the
matically how she's so worried about her
son that she doesn't really care about
the possibility of her hand being
chopped off it's just such a
metaphorically a beautiful scene and one
thing that I want to note is how most of
these are on high levels and bones you
know is known for this a lot of like the
cameras are on eye level in in this
instance you know her crushing down on
the floor so we sort of look at her son
from below to up and that's sort of to
make the audiences real late and that's
why actually if you watch a lot of his
movie except in certain locations he
doesn't use extremely drastic shots like
from really below from really above it's
mostly just constantly
on the eye level and even when she's
like you know outside and tending to her
son everything is almost just I
allowable constantly to give that
emphasis on characters and people and
they the reason why his scenes are so
coherent and so good is because he's
known to be a good story boarder right
yeah he in fact doesn't shoot coverage
and he relies on his storyboards a lot
directors shooting coverage that means
they'll have a couple different camera
angles so that when they're editing they
have options to shoot from either like a
really close up or a little further away
but he draws everything out in
storyboards and usually and only films
that just what he needs just what he
needs so very rarely what will he shoot
any coverage because like coverage I
think some modern directors like kind of
overdo it yeah I'm I'm sort of thinking
about that scene from Thomas Crown
Affair where the two are playing chess
and there's just like inserts after
inserts and there's one overhead and all
sort of it I mean if used well I think
it's good but like it's very surprising
that he does that yeah it's definitely
I'm very unusual they made a book about
oak Joe another of bong Joon hos movies
and in the book there's a couple pages
that show some of the storyboards so I
just wanted to take a look at this one
it lays out this short sequence of
events storyboards also allow for some
technical notes to be thrown in along
with the just the image of what the
cameras gonna be capturing so for
example here it's a Steadicam and then a
lot of arrows as well to help convey
movement to help show kind of what the
cameras will be moving what the
characters are gonna be moving within
frame so in this storyboard this takes
place right after okiya has been taken
from her her giant pig that she's been
caring for for 10 years so let's take a
look at the scene here she figures out
that oak jaw has been taken right here
is he that's the first shot so if we
pause it's pretty similar to that first
storyboard Steadicam showing her running
following her as the arrows indicate
with the camera movement and right here
we get the cool sliding shot down the
hill that he again storyboarded and then
we're gonna get the close-up of her face
here
and then her feet moving with the
Steadicam movement showing she's slowing
down a little bit but still moving
forward
here's that windy road and as I said
it's a wide and then with the pan of the
camera the slow pan to the left and then
finally this last shot here in the
storyboard of her arriving over this
Overlook and seeing that the oak jaw in
the van is off in the distance oh yes he
had everything planned out we we often
use like the term visionary a lot when
when discussing good directors but I
think this is just it just shows how
visionary of a director he is so El
Camino came out this past weekend and we
just wanted to quickly highlight one
Easter egg that we thought was great
that maybe only superfans would have
caught so in this scene here Jesse's in
the diner and if you look at the floor
right here there's two Mis colored tiles
and they're in the shape of the Breaking
Bad title that is an amazing detail so
our team actually broke down a bunch of
other really interesting Easter eggs
from El Camino and you can watch that
video if you go to our YouTube page so
that was it for this episode we'll see
you next time I was gonna somehow add
that like how different directors
approach storyboard different like as
Werner Herzog said storyboards are for
cowards but I don't think that's
relevant